was like uh E40 always at these Warriors
games or was this something the joke
okay you know he was loyal I love 40.
that's my guy he was loyal to the soil I
just want to make sure he's keeping that
energy because him and I argue all the
[ __ ] time about sports he's always
from he was always front row 40. even
that's the one thing about the bay not
the Chinese subject that was always dope
was the Bay always show love like the
like that we believe team we made
history but they had been booed but it
always the fans were always crazy it
always smelled like weed in Oracle like
the bay was the best that was such a
crazy uh just it was what was it you
Michael Petrus Baron Davis hey Rich
Stephen Jackson Al Harrington Monte
Ellis beadrants
Beatrice that big tall German from
Lafayette he's from one of those [ __ ]
yeah he could drink his ass off boy they
used to call him Goose because he would
in the club with the whole
thing of goose when did you leave the
Warriors
um eight nine 2008 2009 so I was there
2006 seven Monty Ellis was coming off
the bench on that team when you that was
supposed to say Monte was the most
improved player that year I think in the
NBA but he rotated from he went back and
forth from starting coming off the bench
I started off he was a bucket man oh man
my head was a killer